feel free to swear if you want otherwise
just be you Jenny we're rarely in real
life yeah I think we'll be okay
well actually let's talk about that
because do you swear not so much in real
life because it may then come out on
camera or are you just not a swear I
really was never a swear you up my
family was kind of strict I'd say we
were the Minnesota family we're at
dinner we all sat there and said how was
your day
please and thank you and swearing was
just like shut up with a swear word am i
yeah yeah so I just never really gotten
a habit but the funny story is they film
me playing hockey once for a fox feature
and I was like dropping f-bombs
all over on the night did you know you
were swearing like no no you were weird
like edit that out it's like I'm playing
yeah edited Lee I get more time what
time was family dinner at the Taft house
well you know it's pretty consistent 631
yeah yeah but it was always you know
before after practices and it was just
my brother and I so we were always like
close and family dinner I didn't realize
how nice it was to have that but it was
kind of a big thing for us now your
brother just finished playing
professionally yeah where who did he
play for played in college at Carter
college I played for two years in
Germany in one of their lower leagues
and loved it but you're not making a ton
of money cool experience but he just
moved here knees on my couch yeah okay
what helped enough I think it's funny I
played you know bring it back to me I
played low-level tennis but the
difference between low-level tennis you
don't make any money in any low level
but I'm not getting like physically
punched you know like room it's like
these football guys that go to Italy or
Germany and play and hockey like not
only are you not getting paid but
someone could knock your teeth out that
night yeah I'm so surprised he has all
this - you know they don't do and he has
like a big smile like yeah luckily if
you lost one of these yeah it's hard to
miss it
now what's your what's your hockey
background um so I grew up in Minnesota
and I all you really have to say hockey
background no right everyone so I say I
grew up playing hockey and then I go
field hockey I'm like no actually ice
hockey real hockey
um I actually had a chance to play this
last winter with Wayne Gretzky I know he
told me about it right I was like the
best day of my life
he said um took a picture sure I was the
only girl so obviously yeah I stood out
I score a couple did you score it so
what that so what was did you play in
college though I didn't play in college
I I was going to play either ice hockey
or lacrosse college and for whatever
reason I really wanted to play lacrosse
different
I grew up hockey was my whole life right
my dad played my brother it was like let
me try something different in Boston use
where I went to college I walked on
there great oh it was great I loved it
great for years but I probably should
have played hockey there were you doing
broadcasting TV when you were in college
yeah that was the gold blue had a really
good journalism program too I always
wanted to be a sports reporter and
lacrosse was a goal as well and I was
able to kind of do both which was really
special
the cross was pretty badass it was okay
I mean there were times where I had
bruises yeah and I had a teacher pull me
aside of you it was really uncomfortable
but lacrosse you you don't want any pads
yeah women lacrosse there but you do
really use your like you have to use and
you get smacked yeah that was it forward
so yeah
defenders really get in and I I had
bruises somebody thought so it was you
know you're like Osage you're like no
professor I kick the [ __ ] out of him I'm
actually fine you know I like I've
always liked hockey lacrosse soccer
players that are females and let me tell
you why I'm and hold on before you start
it's calling me a sexist they just like
there's such a physical toughness
component to those sports soccer maybe
not as much but those girls are always
really tough in it just make it just
makes a well-rounded person like tennis
players who my favorite sport they just
get to be too spoiled and to potential
there's something about getting hit
mm-hmm that makes everybody just kind of
chill out a little bit like their ego
can't get too high mm-hmm am i right
would you say with this or not no I mean
I think there's something to with an
individual sport verse teams
it's still a defeat Allen maybe that's
it I said you get this in high school
just all the way up ties yeah but like I
never was able to get past that
individual I liked the team yeah saying
I went to the French Open I tell you
that I think I saw that on your
Instagram which is what what's your
Instagram well I don't eat after I
didn't apologize about that what was
that all about it was just a friend of
mine worked for she had worked for be in
sports in the pattern she had a lot of
tennis connections and she said I've got
tickets to the French Open are you free
on a weekend haha you're definitely not
and I was why don't all [ __ ]
challenge Jenny you travel so much or
what yeah and I speak French I went to a
French movie French oui oui
pity put our only French speakers so I
thought well I can't not go yeah and it
was such a cool experience
I'd never seen any kind of tennis like
that yeah and it was pretty fun I think
it's the best slam to watch just because
the points are so long yeah like this
weird the surface makes it weird they
have to like slide and they can't just
stop and start yeah so I mean we're
seeing right now if you want to talk
sports because we're seeing right now
with hardcore tennis which is the
American surface everyone's injured okay
like so much harder on you it's so much
harder and men women they're all pulling
out trying to make sure that they're
healthy for the US Open but it's like
it's not a great surface I think we have
the wrong sir what did you what's your
favorite I was best on hardcore it's hot
but I loved clay but I just would lose
on clay is it just because you had more
experience yeah now my game was suited
to attacking okay and a faster court
like a hard court can that could be a
benefit I mean one thing I love about
tennis is the surface changes and hockey
it changes but it's like it just slows
down as the period goes on and I mean
like the ice in different temperatures
different governments you know the ice
affects the game but it's not like your
strategy is kind of design changes yeah
when is your birthday
September 5th September big one coming
up you do what which one is it one of
three yeah yeah we are 30 so that what I
was thinking we should redo this
interview after that because I feel like
I worry a big one everyone's like what
are we going to do I'm not a birthday
person okay I don't I could care less
I'm really not I don't believe that I
really don't care okay because I don't
like putting a lot of pressure on
something right to be something special
yeah that's I mean when look what we've
learned through over a hundred episodes
of this award-winning podcast you never
want to work is it's fun well this one
will Jennie taps episode well is the
higher the expectations usually the
worse the birthday not always but
sometimes just unexpected things have
true and I'm excited to hear what your
worst birthday is but first what's
what's a September 5th going up in
Minnesota that's a good time well it's
okay it's a kicker oh yeah first day of
school a la shift well I mean till Labor
Day for school I had a lot of really bad
first I mean they're kind of excited for
the first day but then it's like your
birthday and you don't want to tell your
new friends like oh by the way my
birthday birthday yeah and you know
you're getting like school supplies from
your parents like I hated that it was
you know what are you gonna do I
remember I always four weeks before
school started I would plan my first day
outfit always but then I never ever
thought about any other days after that
I was like a two-week planner like I was
laying out right I love sports like
fashion I love that stuff I've always
liked it I was like laying it out yes
visualizing do you determine what you
wear on camera now yeah the socks where
you want help you yeah they'll I have a
wardrobe budget which is really nice and
the order of people are they I know you
know them like they're great yeah it was
so nice it's nice to have someone
helping you out especially for I cover a
lot of different sports and a lot of
different climates so like you're a few
extra jackets here and there I mean
soccer versus motocross yeah those are
much different outfit choices aren't
they yes very different I mean I throw
away the boots I wear during motocross
at the end of the year like I just leave
them in the hood they've had their time
but it's a lot of like leather jackets
for Moto you got a play with your yeah
you got it
but soccer it's like mostly summer warm
yeah um this year I got promoted to the
a team for college football here we go
is exciting that's exciting and we have
big ten so we're going to have some cold
games I'm excited about it always makes
me laugh when
and they throw to someone who's outside
the studio and they're like in the in
the thing like this you know and like
that'll be you yeah let's go you get
some cool winter jackets maybe I hope so
and they were so funny they're like you
know it's gonna be really cold yeah
Michigan Ohio State and like I'm from
Minnesota guys like if anything if I can
do this if you get the guy that game I
do I have it it's for sure
so I remember signing they would give us
cool jackets when I was on Fox Sports 1
and then I would you like to Jack I go
yeah if we could just take the fs1 logo
off of these [ __ ] awesome jacket
that's how it work you can't do anything
okay so what's your what your work
what's your worst birthday worst
birthday so it goes back to be you okay
freshman year frost year okay you have
you know no friends when you're a
freshman little nerve-wracking so Matt
be you I don't know anyone what what led
you to deciding on B you were lucky
thing or well it was the journalism
school for sure I actually wanted to go
to BC I had talked to their coaches but
I I went there and I didn't like it like
it was it like a visitor so yeah I just
it didn't it felt very I mean it's a
beautiful campus sure but beyou is in
the city I mean you're in it and I loved
walking around I would take the T
everywhere I would go just to study at a
little cafe over by Fenway like I loved
the idea of exploring yeah so be you
just felt better and then the journalism
school but so freshman year in your dorm
you don't know anyone
yeah it's an awkward time awkward a far
away from home
no no friends I knew no one in Boston I
guess that's half the reason I wanted to
go I thought that'd be fun and we have a
coed dorm which is that school and
different I didn't really know what to
expect
two girls as roommates who find out
against your facebook which was like new
it Wow it was probably the facebook.com
then I was the Facebook you have a
college email I remember that yeah yeah
yeah so they knew it was my birthday
okay so are these random random
assignments yeah grant I mean Claflin
hall I think we lived on 11th floor I
had two roommates
it was a room for two people but we were
three so it's tight quarters and they
decided to plan a surprise but for nice
it's nice except you
notice I know anyone on the floor so
it's the first day of school and I guess
they had invited everyone yeah on the
floor from eleventh a class with a lot
of little leaven or it was maybe it was
14th it wasn't it was Claflin though I
don't know fliers were sent out but if
everyone was invited we have like 40
people yeah like no one came oh like
five people showed up and I remember
they were singing for me and I was like
who are who are these people that are at
this party and they decorated the room
so the thought was really no no I
brought a picture oh yeah actually found
this well post the picture on worst
birthday calm you guys I'm Jenny tells
worse birthday thank God he's a cake oh
my god even know her I don't I think it
was your roommate no oh she was part of
the attendees any Erin what do you think
about that can you can you get that it's
kind of fun but then if you scroll kind
of getting okay so we'll post that on
worst British doctor over the right I
don't buy the way never just scroll
phone left or right there may not be you
video yeah so that's the dorm that's the
first day oh I am right I was so nervous
my babe you were not my favorite thing
about every dorm is there's always by
the way you got to email those to me
cortex whatever II well I was just
letting song I'm very glad you found
them but it was just the fact that I
didn't know anyone and it was a nice
thought right it was awkward and so you
felt like I mean it is really nice they
tried to do that but who so who is that
woman that's a I think her name is Sarah
was she your roommate no no she live
down the hall yeah but she's saying for
me that's really nice I mean and what's
what's too bad about that is if it was
just two or three weeks later yeah your
birthday I would have been all in you
would have been well you would have
known every you would have known hey and
make sure you can right there makes
because because like college it's you
meet in your gym friends real fast yeah
but this was like day number I was like
come over and meet Jenny on her birthday
it ended up being it was a very nice
thing that they did for course but it
was I remember thinking like I am so
alone right now like these are random
strangers how long did it take you to
feel more comfortable for freshmen
because I remember feeling very alone
freshman year yeah
you can and I had a team thankfully
which really I felt alone on a team oh
you just are [ __ ] alone you know I
mean you when you leave your home and
your parents it just feels that way so
how long did it take you to feel okay I
the funny thing is I remember this so
clearly but I don't remember a lot from
freshman you know you feel like that
like it was a blur yeah it was just
asked what's going on I guess having a
team helped a lot I was on the lacrosse
team so I had a lot of friends that way
but you're still like figuring out your
yourself
I took the worst classes my grades were
bad freshman year like it was kind of a
blur I'm like let's just leave her down
here in the past but I loved Boston and
that part was was it a reset I assumed
it was a it was an underage drinking
school oh yeah and I mean it wasn't as
big of a deal yeah I I mean as you can
tell like what's crazy is you're in
college right you can tell by that
haircut that you weren't the craziest
person yeah crazy um but you you could
go to bars and you just wouldn't drink
you're allowed to get into the bar and I
mean now you can't do that at all yeah
yeah I remember going out and it was
never an issue in Boston but now it's
lost after college binge drinking I
don't know what you're allowed to say
I'm not allowed to say because you're
currently you represent some
universities week by week but it just
seems like it would be healthier to let
younger people legally drink than what
normally goes on which is you sneak
somewhere shut the door and like pound a
fifth of vodka or fake ID it into a bar
I'll speak on behalf of my college yeah
there was so much secret drinking
because the cops may show up alibis just
like this is dumb every other first
world country if you're over 18 or even
15 or whatever you thought you're
allowed to drink responsibly it seems
like we're more irresponsible I think
because people drinking is this like oh
it's yeah it's illegal but when you're
in Europe it's totally fine to have wine
when you're growing up I mean I was an
exchange student and like I had wine
with dinner in middle school and I
didn't realize just a little bit in
France yeah you got France that's right
French
yeah well the French school I grew up
going to and I was an exchange student
but they go you have this weird thought
that it's bad and I think that's why
alcohol and binge drinking is such a
problem because people go to school and
it's like well why not
I mean you've covered these football
games yeah these kids they're just
[ __ ] wasted right I mean it's you you
see the fan section my favorite game
here I'll never forget last year was at
BYU okay like the nicest fans yeah I won
so bad like yeah Jenny you know like
cheering for me and I was like this is
my like nicest fans all the BYU kids
yeah I remember watching them in
basketball lot live versus San Diego
State and watching the the behavior of
San Diego State fans versus it's amazing
it really is wonderful it's amazing it
makes you go like oh I wish you know all
of our kids had those values had you
must have been you must be heckled quite
a bit sometimes when you're out there
yeah I guess I mean I guess college is
probably nicer than for example I was at
Azteca for us Mexico which was insane
yeah they had a security guard was that
men's or women's forget it was meant
those men it was World Cup qualifying so
big deal they ended up tying which is
huge
I mean they haven't won in Mexico yeah I
mean they'd I guess it was a friendly
but it wasn't a World Cup qualifying
match so at I was huge to get a point
there and most of this is the stadium it
seats like over all saying yeah they've
done renovations I think the numbers are
more like 85 nine okay um but it was the
loudest atmosphere I've ever experienced
and they told me people will throw
things at you right and it might not be
beer but it will be yellow and it's
probably a better yes it's like actually
that's how bad it is what a roundabout
way my way people will throw piss on you
it won't be beer but it will be yellow
yeah
sorry but you didn't get hit I didn't
get hit people were throwing things yeah
um and there's security around yeah he I
had a guy he was immanuel some amazing
mister keeping me safe I know he listen
you listen sure but I was a little
nervous because that was different
yeah but at the same time in sports like
that atmosphere is once-in-a-lifetime
and it was the coolest experience to be
at Azteca and to feel the energy and I
mean that's why I like sideline
reporting is because you get to
experience it so it was pretty cool so
tell me this because this is something
that always fascinates me what time was
the
name that day do you remember was like a
one o'clock game no it was later which
was also a big deal because there was a
compromise there normally Mexico can
decide like I'm we're going to play it
one not humid the altitude there's
really chair advantage yet to their
advantage but there was some kind of it
they changed the date for Mexico and so
the United States is like well alright
let's play at night it's for oh there
was a little bit of a compromise that
helped a lot it was a lot of cooler okay
and it has been in the past there so
tell then maybe okay so take me through
your day of the game so if it's seven
o'clock game like what are you because
you can always prepare more right oh
yeah
so what do you do all day don't tell me
how that day works well I think it's
every sort little different if it's
soccer and in that situation right we
had been there for the last two day so
we went to us trading the last two days
so that's when I talked to players you
know the days leading up I'm not talking
to players on a game day that are in any
sport and you have access to the players
I do I have access and that's also
relationships you know not being close
with the press Secretariat
I'm I have good relationships with the
guys because I've now been around them
for a while so I think if needed I would
reach out to a press secretary maybe get
someone on the phone the night before
like the US was going with a different
keeper truer than expected and that was
something that I wanted to get a word
from him so I'll quickly you know talk
to them and get an update but morning of
is we have a meeting okay with everyone
like what time like in 7:00 a.m. a time
at the hotel everyone at the hotel so
that's our pre-show group that's
everyone in the room asylum yeah in a
conference room at our hotel and you
know the Fox executives are there I mean
there's a big meeting yeah we go don't
show I'm hungover to that one no no good
not any of that
come on I'd be on camera not you like
our crew will go out I'm like you guys
have fun but like I'm on air tomorrow so
this isn't going to end well and as you
get older Jenny I'm older than you
it's like you can't drink like three
days before because your face shows a
[ __ ] longer and [ __ ] that's just
like that's why I meet all these guys
are like 50 I'm like and like you don't
drink like I stopped drinking like 10
years ago
see it forever still see it anyway so
camera angle I mean gone I am NOT I like
I could I am NOT I'm a confident person
I really care but like it adds pounds
sure let's be on an HD isn't helping no
but I'm like a muscle on your arm isn't
necessarily a muscle right on that wide
leg direct expands meeting I look
through my notes I've got like maybe I
have 15 stories about different players
that could be relevant maybe they have a
history against Mexico so-and-so scored
and you know this last time they met up
someone has a relationship with the
coach anyway any story that might be
relevant I just kind of go through my
notes and then I because something may
happen where you're called on that story
yeah
like see that is the last four years ago
he did same goal on that guy whatever
right like how why I'm not a sideline
repeated same goal same Golf tango turbo
but the thing about sideline that I
think no one realizes is I have all of
these stories that you'll never hear and
that's okay I'm going
it's that's part of the job but people
say well what does a sideline reporter
do and half the time one I'm listening
to the coach and I'm watching the bench
if I see an injury I can get an update
so I'm normally right there listening to
the coach how I'm close to the best
[ __ ] Mexico though no because they
have controls yeah you're not you can
sit behind the net I mean why I would
never want a reporter close to the bench
but you but you see it always and
college football I have I know which
coaches are okay with me I I tread
lightly on Jerome coaches who I have a
relationship with some teams will tell
you an injury some like sorry so I can
just tell you what I'm reporting if
someone's limping and he's clutching oh
right all screaming [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my
ankles I can say I can say that without
that right you can't say that not that
part so hard so I think there's a
misconception and and correct me if I'm
wrong that there's some producer out
there organizing that for you yeah no
it's always usually you yeah I have a
sideline producer for soccer for mainly
though for the international games to
actually just coordinate interviews with
their press because there's
a lot of action but he's not watch I
mean health if he's if you see something
happen he'll say Jen like so-and-so's
limping you don't look at that right but
I don't have someone for college
football the problem there and a lot of
people have one you can't be on both
side lines at sure time so you kind of
have to judge the energy of a side and
sometimes you get caught and you're like
whoa I've been on USC sideline for way
too long I gotta go over here that's
hard right harder and football's got to
walk all the way around the family
people like you you get spoiled when you
cover soccer because you know that group
of guys and then football the roster
know so many and it's literally like
both sides of the team in soccer it's
just so I think that's really
interesting that that a lot of your
access story interview comes down to how
you manage finagle your relationships
with those coaches that's very very much
a skill set it's interesting like I'm
going to USC practice today I haven't
seen coach Helton since last year I want
to check in with their si D and you have
to take advantage of being in LA and
having your access or but USC is a great
example they totally get it I mean they
understand TV they understand it's their
advantage to allow me to talk to their
coach because he's gonna I mean it's not
rocket science whatever he tells me I'm
gonna that's the quote I mean I I'm not
no making up anything wherever it makes
sense right so they understand that and
I think some schools are just really
careful maybe they've had bad
experiences in the past with stories
getting out but the difference between
like college and NFL NFL has to tell you
injuries right they don't have to tell
you anything right they don't well okay
but they're in college too it's all
about recruiting so they want to be in
control of the story and yeah so they
must also feed you wrong information I
mean I haven't had that happen a lot of
times it's we think it's this he's going
to be evaluated further in the locker
room we'll let you know if there's an
update which you know I've had
situations where they've said so-and-so
its dehydration and it looks like a knee
and you're like really
dehydration like it
and then he was like my ass off to
reporters I feel like it could be to
your advantage
yeah but then you saw that you're bad
yeah I mean I got that from I go well he
can't line them I don't know I
appreciate you saying that you're
welcome yeah
okay so morning meeting 10:00 a.m. Lexi
lawless Fox executives blah blah blah
then what happens then I normally go on
a run yeah kind of like clear my head a
lot of times you are kind of wasting
time those long days a lot of waiting I
like the noon kick for football you're
you're in you're out leave take the all
nighter home yeah um and then I just
really go as early as I can I watch
practice I mean you watch warm-ups you
do a lot of interviews you know I'll
talk to a player off the bus I'll talk
to a coach off the bus on camera or no
uh yes it should be in theory but like
for those international games it's weird
because FIFA a lot of times in charge so
you might not see me but that's all a
FIFA rule in LA right
very weird right right in college
football I'm on or yeah I'll do a report
pre kick so you're kind of just getting
your stories ready but a lot of times
and I've learned this you might have all
these ideas and then something happens
and it changes in a second so but you
need to be need to be prepared just be
prepared
yeah and I I really enjoy it I think
it's the I likes to do and it's a little
more rehearse than you know studio but I
can never predict what's going to happen
to the game and I guess I like that
that's got to be the most exciting yeah
you know just and getting caught up in
the excitement in the moment yeah I'm
you can't help it today horse when I
think Colorado last year they storm the
field I mean that it was unbelievable
and I'm like trying to catch cefalu foul
who's the senior quarterback who's like
had this crazy story enough he's had a
great year and I can't find him and
they're like pulling the fans are
pulling you but it's one of those things
were coolest thing ever it is always
funny after a game especially football
trying to watch you guys get the get to
the coach or the quarterback it's like
geez I was like it's isn't someone else
gonna be in charge of that now has me
it's you so let's get back to the worst
birthday for a second because I think
this is something a lot of incoming
freshman people that are new
anything can feel like it's like lonely
people are even trying to make it nice
for you but it stills doesn't work
what's your what what did you take away
from that worst birthday if you took
away anything I guess it was just really
it was very thoughtful yeah I remain and
it set up you know I think the other
thing is you get these roommates
assignments and you start looking them
up like on Facebook right and are
immediately judging them who are these
people I remember this one girl Amanda
who I need to reach out to her she was
one of the two she know she listens to
yeah she listened yeah and you know her
picture was something that gave me a bad
impression I'm like who is this girl and
she ended up she was unique she she did
not she slept during the day so she
studied all night I mean we were so
opposite but she was the coolest best
roommate and I totally judged that I
wouldn't like her sure she was great so
you can't do that well that's what I
think that's a great thing to take away
from it it I think when I went to
college there wasn't Facebook so you
just kind of saw their name and you
would judge my their name which you
would do that too you know I would go
coughs yeah well this guy that's weird
you don't have anything to base it on I
remember I was living with my college
teammate Jamal Parker but he had checked
that he wanted to be like in a
african-american wing
oh so it was me and like 40 black dudes
now a lot of people who come from where
I came or would go like I don't want
that and I didn't want that and then
once I got to know everybody it was
great but that's that's what you will
figure out so much in college
it's like oh I don't think I'm gonna
like this oh my god these are my friends
these are my friends now yeah and it
works out I loved College yeah I don't
want to go back let's go especially how
much you have like real responses like I
get it now how I could do that
successfully are you do you keep in
touch with those roommates at all or
well I know that I bring up her name I
need to reach out to her as we did for a
while and she was like traveling the
world I mean she was awesome and my
college lacrosse teammates yes no it's
hard a lot of them live out east so I'm
so far I mean no one is this way when
will lacrosse start to migrate out of
the East well surprisingly it has
I went to AB you played USC last year
and USC which is a newer program I don't
know how long they've had a team but
they coming to kill Bo like I was high
left it was like well you know if you
you have USC it makes sense they can
recruit girls from all over so it does a
lot of East Coast girls coming to USC
but it actually has shifted West
Colorado has a lot of benefits of course
Western when I played was dominant which
was just a random kind of Midwest but
they had this great coach that brought
the team there and long story short it's
growing it's what it is it is associated
with wealth correct look right yeah I
think I'm like you know the Annapolis
Baltimore you know the prep school yeah
for sure is that because of the
equipment is that just in the history of
it the history but I don't really know
like why the prep school thing is
nothing I mean but out east it's like
you're born playing lacrosse yeah some
of those goodies so Oh
lacrosse fit right lacrosse ladies and
gentlemen is the national sport for
Canada yeah I did a story about that you
did bu journalism school I should send
it also your way send it to work Bertha
calm where can people find all of the
information that is Jenny Taft
um I guess social media wise I try to
post as much on Twitter and that's Jenny
Taft and then Instagram is Jenny test as
well it's Fox monitoring your tweets and
do they do they say like hey you can't
really say that's it but you don't
really you don't really have less
controversial stuff out I don't know I
maybe I should get more involved I feel
like lately it's hard I I am don't tell
me your opinion on that on everything
well do this social me is it is it your
do you feel like you should be more
opinionated in the public eye or do you
feel like your job is to keep it calm
and let everyone else around you go
crazy I think in the role I have as a
sideline reporter and I am reporting
facts I find my platform right now
shouldn't be personal opinions as much
as sports specific stuff because I don't
want it I think that gets a little
confusing could I have a little of both
maybe I think Fox is pretty open about
they encourage their personalities to be
to have opinions that are look at Colin
coward skip bayless I mean we've got
these guys that are known for having
these opinions so I think in general
that's okay but they're on a different
kind of a show than me as a sideline
reporter so I guess I try to maybe I'm
too careful
but I like to keep it I wasn't I wasn't
suggesting that but just so you know I
was just curious because you have a
platform yeah
but like you said as any good team a
team sport athlete is you need to
understand what your role is Skip's role
he was hired to probably have the
headline circle around them and that
isn't necessarily probably what you were
hired to do yeah um let's finish with a
best birthday you've had if you can
think of margin I didn't ask you to
prepare this but is there anything that
comes to mind was when you were kid or a
gift you got or maybe when you're on the
road working um maybe it's going to be
the 30th coming up I hope it is to
remember something fun yeah do you have
anything planned
oh no well I have a friend who said
let's plan something but I don't like
putting pressure oh yeah
I don't want people to feel like I have
to do something for you people come to
this comedy store yeah come on that's a
great birthday be fine really is fun
okay maybe that I will say I will say
this as someone that doesn't do a lot of
worse birthdays if you want it to be
great you do need to plan okay what
happens is people want it to be great
and they don't [ __ ] plan anything
and that's disaster day it's going to be
great it's 30 no it's not it's like New
Year's Eve you know it's a lot of
build-up it's never really that good
that's why don't like New Year's Eve
it's like The Comedy Store is a great
birthday maybe number fifth yeah yeah
there which is what is that a Monday
well it's a day after Labor Day so oh
yeah say last night is at work are you
available I'm available that's a good
that's a great night at The Comedy Store
but in general days after national
holidays are not so good okay so could
we go on go on Labor Day go whenever
that whatever you want to go so no best
birthday probably no no okay last year
actually we were on the road for soccer
yeah and they threw me a big dinner
unexpected all you know my Fox family
and that really meant a lot because I
wasn't expecting anything we had the
big steakhouse dinner and everyone came
it was just like little things that goes
a long way because when you basically
live on an airplane reduce I miss a lot
of holidays the holidays and maybe
that's why I like you can't I have
worked on Christmas sure Christmas Eve
and st. Irving I mean holidays to me are
kind of this odd thing where you just
don't build them up a lot so maybe
that's I think that's probably a result
of the profession yeah people always
forget that when you're watching NBA
basketball on Christmas Day
yeah it's not like there's thousands of
production crew that are also not having
dinner with their Chris with their
families but it's just part of the deal
with our job yeah and I mean we've had
some amazing and Fox's in a great job
like they put on a big Thanksgiving meal
for us because I've worked Thanksgiving
games or day before and that goes a long
way yeah and so I think people do sports
yes I work in sports it's amazing I love
it but I haven't had a weekend off in a
long time and that's just how it is but
you love it yeah it's just you miss
weddings you miss events weddings are I
can't tell reading there are things I've
missed and like it sucks to say yeah I'm
working because a lot of times people
don't get that you can't get off I hate
it I mean I missed one of my teammates
last year her wedding it killed me but
it's just like I had a game you're also
under contract yeah go cover that game
it's not like you get to pick hey I know
it's Purdue Indiana but I just you know
I'm going to skip that one I as a
struggling stand-up comic you would get
invited to these weddings and you would
have a road date and let's say you're
making a thousand bucks on the road day
like nothing well the weddings going to
cost you another thousand to two
thousand to go to probably so now it's
like a three to four thousand dollar
swing and you try to explain that to the
bride you know and you're like you're
spiritually screwed
so you have a little more respect to
people that work on the weekend
including a Johnny Depp Jenni tab thank
you for sharing your worst birthday this
is fine I'm sorry that that happened to
you but I wanted that bad it wasn't that
bad but I think it was important for
people to hear that story it was fun
yeah it was I wasn't funny though you're
not supposed to be funny
it just goes to be real
what just real quickly what are some big
games you are covering this year so
people can check out yeah so it's I mean
college football's around the corner and
that was my whole fall is exciting to be
I'm going to be with Joel clot and Gus
Johnson and they've been together for a
couple years now so just working with
them is great my first game I've got a
doubleheader the first weekend and it's
Washington at Rutgers ok that's the
first Big Ten game on fs1 ever because
it well I think that we got the Big Ten
and then Sunday Masses yeah you know
it's nice that Sox are starting to get
some real sports yeah I know you can't
play that anyway yeah when I was when I
was at Fox they were covering like the
Red Bull ice skating championship IRA
may have been on the sidelines what have
I not covered yeah well you've been
there since the inception of the network
so that's funny it's getting some real
games now yeah and they're putting I
mean big ten of course is huge for for
football and then I've got am at UCLA
well on Sunday and that cool at Sunday
game well that'd be on the well ok and
then the big the Big Ten Network is also
a Fox property yeah yeah we're not
working for that or you know it's I mean
we have like fifty percent of the games
between ESPN and Fox oh and there's some
kind of it's so complicated on who gets
what games yeah but there's a lottery
system it's all vary but it all kind of
depends on how teams perform and then
there's a priority on who wants what
game sadly no one but nobody wants my
alma mater University of Illinois but
maybe this year maybe this year maybe
the sir I like Rob I have a game you're
coming I'd love to do that thank you for
sharing your wares birthday thanks for
having me alright Jeff Jenni Taft
everybody see that's easy right